Even though I walked through the valley of the shadow of death. I
will not fear for you are with me. You are
my light and my salvation.
You restore me and Lead Me For Your
Glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning to you church. It's great to see you on this spring
forward Sunday all bright-eyed. I can
tell everybody's wide awake. I know you lost an hour
sleep, but it's okay because you're here. And so that's all that matters.
We're excited to be together. If you're new to our church.
We're thankful. You would come we hope you're welcome and
encouraged and and challenged in your pursuit of Jesus
while you're with us. We'd love to get to know you if we can so, please
figure out a way for that. It's right and see back in front of
you or just come say hello.
But if you've been around Henderson Hills for any length of time, you know that almost
four years ago. Now we began a Year's long
journey. It's gonna takes about 15 years that we
figured out to get through the book of Psalms one by one. So we're
gonna take him one at a time 150 there and we hit
him in the Summers. We hit him on these what we call shoulder weeks
like this around spring break. So we're gonna
take a while so stick around and we'll get there eventually by the
way, Alan Rice one of our elders took the Psalms
and and repoatized them back into
English the way that they might have read in the original language
and that's available out at the bookstore. If you want to
be it as a part of the psalm study use those
in your own time.
But before we hit the couple week run up
to Easter that's coming in a few weeks. We are going to
today and next Sunday take the next Psalms up
in order. That's how we're going through. I'm just one at a time. And so
what we're doing today is Psalm 53.
So if you're not there yet already turn in your copy
of God's word to Psalm 53. It's funny as we've walked through
these every one of these has been very timely just not
planning which order and how we get there right
when we're doing them. It's just whatever's next and so Psalm
We'll see today is very timely as well. Now before we
get into it though. I have an interesting fact about
this Psalm that we need to be aware of before we get
into it Psalm 53 is almost identical to
Psalm 14.
We studied Psalm 14 back in December of 2019. So
it's been three and a half years ago. But except for
verse 5, they're identical nearly.
Now why would that have occurred?
Don't you think that the people who are collating the scriptures back
then would have seen that and been like removing the
duplicate.
Like when I poured out a handful of Skittles in my hand when
I was a kid, I was always eat the duplicates and just leave the five single
ones right, by the way, that was
back when there was the good stuff the lime not this green apple garbage,
right? The lime stuff was good.
Why would they have left to duplicate though?
Don't you think they would have seen that? Well, it's kind of like the way.
In modern musicals the way Melodies and
rhythms work in modern musicals. You see something
happen early and then it continues on and shows
up again. Later.
But it adds depth that adds meaning and it's a different context and
you learn something about how the musical is working
because of that it develops the storyline as it
fits into the new context.
And so as we look at Psalm 53, yeah lots going
to sound the same as it did three and a half years ago.
But think just for a second how much
has changed in the last three and a half years?
Right. That was BC that was before covid. So everything
has has changed a lot
since then, right? We've all walked through and have
a different perspective in so many things.
That time in our lives revealed a lot.
Just a couple things first. It had it revealed where we
had been putting our hope.
in
our work or finances
Or our planning of our lives or our
government or whatever else that we've been put a lot
of Hope in those things and it exposed that but also that time
revealed how much each of us desires control.
And how when any semblance of that control is
lost?
And people lose it, right. We saw that in
that time frame.
And so I believe each one of us is going to be impacted today by
this repeated psalm.
In a fresh way. We'll see something today. So
Psalm 53 look at it with me now.
The fool says in his heart there is no God.
They are corrupt doing abominable iniquity. There's
none who does good.
God looks down from heaven on the children of man to see if
there are any who understand who seek after God.
And they've all Fallen away.
Together they've become corrupt. There's none who
does good. Not even one.
Have those who work evil. No knowledge.
Who eat up my people as they eat bread and do not call upon God.
There they are in great Terror where there is no Terror.
For God scatters the bones of him who encamps against
you you put them to shame for God has rejected
them.
Oh the salvation for Israel would come out of Zion.
When God restores the fortunes of his people let Jacob
Rejoice let Israel be glad.
God help us see what you want us to see today in your
word.
Give us good soil in our hearts that we would receive this and
it would bear good fruit in our lives.
Challenge us where we need it convictus I pray
for someone today who's hurting they be comforted by this.
Lead us in your way everlasting God.
in Jesus name
amen
now just like Psalm 14. This one was also written by David. He
was in a tough spot in his life. He's he's looking around
and he's seeing few people like him that are
pursuing Yahweh. And so it was so bad for him
at this point it got to the point where where he even used one of the strongest biblical
words for someone who had turned away from God and
we saw that in verse 1, that's the word fool.
The Biblical word fool has has so
much behind it. But but listen, it has very
little to do with someone's intellectual capacity.
That's how we often use it today. But but biblically it has
more to do with someone's spiritual capacity.
With with who they are in their
relationship with God where they're Pursuits in Life
or taking them. That's what it means when it says fool.
So it's used here in Psalm 53 that someone who has turned away from
God look at the result. They've become futile. They've become
worthless.
You might call them a good for nothing.
And so when we look at that picture we see yes fools
around us everywhere.
I mean certainly we see fools everywhere on social
media every day on streaming services at school
at work. We see fools all
around us, but instead of merely pointing the
finger outward at everybody else.
I wanted to see that that we can be
foolish as well.
Every one of us can be foolish. Yes fools are
everywhere, but it including inside us.
That there's a fool there, too.
Here's how we get to that. Here's how here's how we can say that.
First what we learn from Psalm 53, is that the fool lives
as if there is no God.
The fool lives as if there is no God, that's
what it says. Right the fool says in his heart. There is no God.
Verse 1 says that that in the deepest part of who he
is or she is the deepest part
of who they are. They've declared absolute Independence.
There's no Authority.
And you see in verses 1 through 4 how that plays out which
that attitude in their heart brings corruption.
It brings evil Deeds. It brings ignorance. It could
even get to the point where somebody starts attacking Believers. That's
what saying no God in
your heart gets to
Now again, this is not saying anything about a person's intellectual
capacity.
Because some of the smartest people in the world can also be the
most foolish.
So why David writes here that if a person claims God does
not exist.
It's not that they are misguided in their belief. And
that's it. No, it's actually a gesture of
defiance.
Romans 1:22 says claiming to
be wise they became fools.
And we we know it we have it all together and that's
how they get to being a fool. So this
is not here. This this is not merely philosophical atheism.
Where someone has faith that God does not
exist.
It's not merely philosophical atheism. This is
actually functional atheism.
Where someone is living as if God doesn't exist.
It's what Romans 1:28 says that they
did not see fit to acknowledge God.
It's an act of defiance but it's also an act of
trying to avoid culpability trying to avoid
any potential judgment and saying I don't I don't want to
deal with that. And so no, there's no God.
And so yes, this is when someone says
intellectually an atheist says no, there's no God living
like that. Yes, but see that this
same truth can also be true of anyone.
It can even be true of us as Believers that this can happen that
the fool still lives inside us as well.
Because the reality is no one likes to submit, right?
That that flesh that's inside of
us Rises up when something threatens its Authority
threatens. It's it's Direction in our lives the flesh
wants control and if somebody starts attacking that it's gonna rise
up,
But let me be clear about this.
Every time you live outside of
the authority of God in your life.
You choose something do something outside of God's
Authority. You are saying with the fool in verse
1. There's no God.
Functionally, that's what you're saying. Right? Is
that not true?
Is it not functional atheism when you do whatever
you want instead of whatever God
says for you to do.
Like that time, I knowingly swiped the answer
sheet in class.
Put it in my binder.
Or every time I knowingly turned on
the computer to go to that website.
Yet in my mind what was running through
there is saying it's not a big deal.
Nothing's going to happen.
Is that not in essence saying with
the fool? There's no God.
You might intellectually think yeah, of course there is but functionally
in that moment, you're saying
no, there's no God. When you cheat on your taxes. Are
you not saying that there's no God.
When you gossip or you slander or you exclude people
are you not saying there's no God?
plus you're eating up your brothers and sisters like Psalm 53
said
like when you live selfishly not generously you're
saying there's no God.
When you lash out at the waiter who messed up your order, you're
When you watch that show that dehumanizes men
and women into objects for your pleasure. You're saying
there's no God.
Listen, if you live without the fear of God, you
can claim to be a believer all
you want yet you can act and think functionally no
different than anyone else around us.
And because you've said there's no God, I'm gonna do whatever I want
and you might think I'm immune to that. I
can't no I there's no way I could get there listen apart from
Christ.
That's the only way we can live.
It's the only way we can least all right here versus two and
three God looks down from heaven on the children of man to see if
there are any who understands who seek after God. They've all
Fallen away together. They have become corrupt. There
is none who does good not even one.
That's the same argument Paul picks up in Romans chapter 3 when he repeats
this statement and he adds other more intense
phrases explaining our depravity apart
from God.
And I know we talk a lot about that around here that God makes the
believer new spiritually that you are
a new creation. Yes.
But the theological principle here, is that our sinful flesh
still hangs on.
We're still in these flesh suits the sin
Nature's still there even as we're new
and so what that means is that we have been justified
in Christ made right with
God through his bloodshed.
We have been Justified. We are being Sanctified meaning
we're made more like Jesus every day.
But it's still future.
The day that we're going to be glorified.
Which means we're going to be given new bodies that will
be uncorrupted not tainted with sin anymore that sin
nature will be completely gone, but that is still future.
And so until that day that
foolish flesh still wants to
creep up and take over again.
Paul in Romans 7 with this tension of like man, I do what I don't
want to do but I don't do what I want to do and it's like what will deliver
me Jesus?
But we feel the tension, right?
That's what we're talking about here. So yes, there are
fools all around us.
There are people who are living as if they are
their own God.
Or living as if that experience is their God.
Or living as if that identity is their God.
Anything that that you set as ultimate is your god is
what we're talking about when you think about God here, but
you and I can slip into that black hole,
too.
Where we set God aside in our
lives and we effectively live like an unbeliever again.
There's no God.
But here's what King David saw. He was
lamenting this reality.
He saw it all around him back then but he saw a
glimmer of the future.
in verse 5
There they are in great Terror where there is
no Terror.
For God scatters the bones of him who encamps against
you you put them to shame for God
has rejected them.
What David saw here is that the unrepentant fool
receives God's judgment?
The fool says there is no God the unrepentant fool receives
then God's judgment.
This verse 5 is the major difference between Psalm
14 and Psalm 53.
In Psalm 14, there was a there's more of
an emphasis on God protecting his people.
Here the emphasis is on God's judgment.
But notice this judgment in the verse here is is to
relieve God's people temporarily. Yes,
but there's also a judgment that lasts into
eternity.
permanent
there's a temporary judgment where where those who set themselves
against God. It says that God will give them
fear where there is. No reason for them to fear.
Terror where there is no Terror meaning they're gonna be
scared of leaves falling or Shadows coming they're gonna be scared of
things. They shouldn't be scared of
This actually happened in a big way a couple times in
the Old Testament, but here's one.
Second Kings chapter 7 where where the powerful
Syrian Army had besieged Samaria.
And this Army was the most powerful Army at the time and there
was no way that Israel was going to beat them.
And Syria had set up this Siege and
there was absolutely no way they could lose this battle.
But God had promised his people Deliverance.
And he did it in a miraculous way.
For the Lord had made the army of the syrians hear
the sound of Chariots and of horses
the sound of a great Army so that they
said to one another behold the king of Israel has hired against us
the kings of the Hittites and the kings of Egypt to come against
us and so they fled away in the Twilight and
abandoned their tents their horses and their donkeys leaving
the camp as it was and fled for their
lives.
So you see what happened?
Like they're all encamped here. They're all
strong. This Mighty Army. There's no way
they could be beaten, but all the sudden they started hearing something.
And they were scared of the Shadows.
And there was no threat that they actually had but
God caused Terror where there was. No Terror.
And they fled away.
And so it happened back then but listen doesn't that
happen every day, too.
Doesn't this kind of judgment happen today all around
us?
And we see people who are not focused on God
seeming to remain in a permanent
state of panic.
I just worrying about everything.
Never able to rest.
needing to medicate
With substances or sports or streaming
services?
Just always on edge.
Even self-proclaimed Believers can get there, right?
Living in this constant state of anxiety by
trying to carry the whole world on your shoulders.
You remember that sculpture of Atlas maybe a
painting you've seen of it where the guys leaning over got the
whole globe on his shoulder.
I've got a picture of that in my office and I've got a big red
circle with a line through it.
But that's what we get to right.
Listen when you functionally remove God and try
to take on the full responsibility of
Life yourself.
Like all the war in the world all the terrorists and
the world all the disease all the politics all
the family drama in your own like you try to
take God out of that and you carry all that. No wonder
there's Terror
No wonder we're anxious. No wonder we're fearful
and worried.
But we must repent of that.
Because God's people ought not to be that way.
Isaiah 26:3 reminds us you
keep him in perfect. Peace whose mind
is fixed on you.
You see that fixed on you.
And I get it. There's a lot of other things factoring into this. There's there's chemical
I get it.
but the most of us
instead of constantly scrolling through
social media feeds that are just filled with Terror.
Or having your favorite cable news station on 24/7. That's
just pandering to you.
And showing you one way and causing fear
in all of that. What Philippians 4 8
9 says we should do instead is whatever is
true. Whatever is Honorable. Whatever is
just whatever is pure whatever is lovely whatever
is commendable if there's any Excellence if
there's anything worthy of Praise think about these things.
How do you do that?
dig deep into God's word
talk about the gospel with brothers and sisters all the
time memorize scripture. Listen to
sermons sing worship songs. Think
about the Lord just constantly fixing
your mind on him. It's like
that old. Well known him says, right.
Turn Your Eyes Upon Jesus
Look full in his wonderful face.
and the things of Earth
will grow strangely dim.
in the light of his glory and
grace
fixing your mind on him.
It means we can have no fear.
Because God is with us.
That's what David saw and he hoped in.
For God's enemies though.
That's not the case.
God will often temporarily judge them like
we talked about this constant sense of panic all the time,
but there's even worse coming than that.
You see verse 5 talked about God scattering the
bones of his enemies.
Putting them to permanent shame because he's rejected
them.
This is talking about physical death. Of course that this
Army that seems so strong. They might think they're strong.
They cannot stand against the god of creation. He will
win the battle.
But this also points us to something
eternal.
because when you tie it with the next verse verse 6
it talks about salvation coming for Israel talks about
restoring The Fortunes of his people that's talking eternity,
right?
That's talking eternally that God
restores the fortune because it happened temporarily a few times
but it happens eternally permanently fully. That's what
we're seeing. He's referencing here, but then it
also
Ads layers whenever you think about God rejecting people.
That's what he says here. Right? God has rejected them.
Think about it who are the ones that God Rejects?
Well, James, 4:6 says that God opposes the
proud.
And gives grace to the humble.
That word proud there means self-sufficient.
independent
maybe like verse 1 says
there is no God.
And God will reject the proud because they've turned
their backs on him because they have said I don't need you
God they've assumed they could do life on their
own even hear me, even if they're not
actively opposed outwardly opposed
to God or to his people this is
an inward in their heart. They have said
I'm opposed to you God.
There is no God. I don't want you to be Lord.
But that's why here let me remind you.
That's why I said
the unrepentant fool receives
God's judgment
because the reality is that all of us.
Will act a fool at some point in our lives, right?
Each of us will allow that flesh to creep back
up and try to take over some of you have even
this morning. It happened for you, right you felt that creep up
and say no don't do the right thing. I want
you to do what I want you to do, right? The flesh will try to come back
over in that but but this is talking
about
when the full
dominates
when the fool in US is in control, not God.
When we are unrepentant in that attitude.
That's when God's judgment comes.
That's the image we get here from verse 5 of the enemy in camping
against God and his people.
Like they've set up shop in opposition to
the Lord.
It's not just it's not just slipping into that position then
quickly repenting and being back in the presence of God. That's not
what we're talking about. No, this is an active. There's no
God God. I don't need you kind of
opposition.
In fact, it's the lifestyle that we
see.
in First Corinthians 6 verses 9 and 10
Do you not know that the unrighteous will not inherit the
kingdom of God?
Do not be deceived neither the sexually immoral nor
idolaters nor adulterers nor
those who practice homosexuality nor
thieves nor the greedy nor drunkards
nor revilers nor swindlers will
inherit the kingdom of God.
You see that though. Did you notice those are all
habitual positions?
Those are all unrepentant positions.
It's not saying that if you've stolen something in your life, you're
out. It's saying are you a thief?
Is this something you are marked by are you an idolater? Are
you an adulterer is your life marked by
these things that is in camping
against God in Psalm 53.
And saying I've set up shop. This is my identity. This
is who I am. This is what I do. I can't do anything else that's against
God.
And God says he'll put those unbelievers to shame forever.
They've rejected the authority of God their whole
life now. It's just permanent.
The image we get from this word shame.
In verse 5 the image we get from that word is that
these people these Imaging these people as they're walking as
captured prisoners in
a Victory Parade back into the Winning
Side City.
So they've been defeated and they've got chains around their hands
and their feet and they're kind of shuffling down the street.
They got guards right next to them watching over them and they've got the city
celebrating the king's Victory
around them, but they're just shuffling in the parade ashamed.
hear me that's
that's coming for you if you don't repent.
Like and it's it's it hurts me just it doesn't it's
not fun to say that.
But God's word is clear.
If you reject God in any way, he will reject
you.
This is not everybody gets in.
It's not everybody gets a trophy right this is this is
if you reject God, he will reject you you will walk in
Eternal shame.
Thankfully.
Thankfully verse 5 is not the end.
Otherwise, we're all in trouble.
David looked at the trials he and his people were facing.
And he had a glimmer of hope.
He had a glimmer of hope as well. Even though
he saw all this around him. He had a glimmer of hope.
Look at verse 6.
Oh that salvation for Israel would come out
of Zion when God restores the fortunes of
his people.
Let Jacob Rejoice let Israel be
glad.
So there there's a two-fold. Hope here notice first.
David's looking at his enemy and camped around God's people the
enemy threatening his life and David recalled that
fear is always groundless because
God always takes counter action against his
enemies.
God's always at work for his people even
in the moment, right? We we don't even see it
at times. We don't even understand it most of the
time but we know God is working to bring
about his good purpose.
David looked back at all of his history. All of Israel's history
and he knew God was good.
And God's at work.
So salvation is coming at least temporarily we
know that but there was also a bigger Deliverance hinted
at here.
This language. He uses about salvation coming out
of Zion Zion. Remember is is God's Mountain. It's
a symbol for Heaven For Eternity for Jerusalem. The
new one. He's he's pointing that
as the summary of Eternal salvation that
it would bring Salvation. Plus there's
this request to restore the fortunes of
his people plus they're the words about rejoicing and
being glad right all of this has an eternal
ring to it.
Is there's Eternal language feeling in
this?
Which by the way that's that's language used all over
the book of Isaiah.
Same kinds of things over and over again saying hey, this is what's coming.
This is what's coming salvation's coming from Zion. That's
all over Isaiah. But then listen to this
Zechariah 9 verse 9. It is explicit here.
It says Rejoice greatly o
Daughter of Zion.
Shout aloud o daughter of Jerusalem behold.
Your king is coming to you.
Righteous and having salvation. Is
he humble mounted on a donkey
on a Colt the foal of a donkey? Who's that
talking about?
Let's talk about the Messiah the one we now
know as Jesus the prophecy of the king bringing
salvation out of Zion out of
the Mountain of God bringing joy and
gladness to his people you see how this all ties together.
So God is offering hope to his people here.
He's saying to Israel through David you're threatened by enemy Nations.
Hey, you're salvation's coming.
And at times he would bring temporary Deliverance,
but primarily he's offering hope even to
us today.
As we look around and we see an atheistic culture
dominated by lies.
foolishness everywhere around
us
and so he's offering hope that there's coming a day salvation will come from
Zion for us to
but at the same time he's offering a hope to even
the fool here.
because remember
those fools are not only outside of us.
A fool lives inside each one of us.
each one of us
has that fool in side of us?
Remember Romans 3:23 all have sinned and fall short
of the glory of God.
We're all fools apart from
any intervention of God.
And so we're do his judgment. We are really in a
bad place from birth on.
But that's the beauty of the Gospel.
the beauty of the Gospel
is that Romans 3 continues by saying that we are justified by
his grace as a gift through the
Redemption that is in Christ Jesus.
That he came to do it and he offers it as a
gift even to fools.
Like you and me.
See fools go through life thinking that
there is no ultimate Authority.
But Jesus became the wisdom
of God for us First Corinthians 1 says
by fully submitting every moment to his
father and the will of God.
Fools as we saw live Lives full of
sin full of evil Deeds, but there was
no trace of moral corruption in Jesus.
Psalm 53:4 says fools even eat
up God's people
Well, Jesus was eaten up in our place.
By taking on our judgment all of
the weight and penalty of sin poured on to him
in our place. He was the one
who took all of it for us. And so the question
I'm going to ask you.
Do you believe that?
Do you believe that do you believe that he
is who he said he is he did what he said he would do and
he accomplished it all if you believe that
then turn from your sin and yourself and turn to
Jesus with your whole life.
Turn to The God Who is there The God Who is real The
God Who came to save you?
and your life
can be filled with joy even even when
the darkness floods in all around us.
your life
with your eyes fixed on him can be filled with
joy.
and believer listen
We should all rejoice and be
glad.
Right. That's what it said.
It's what it said in Zechariah. It's said
in Isaiah. That's what it says here at the end of verse 6. Let Jacob
Rejoice let Israel be glad like we as the sons
of Israel like we we can believe
and rejoice and be glad and
live trusting obedient lives.
Why?
Because our Salvation has come.
Our wisdom has come and our future
is secure.
No matter what we face every day.
those Eternal truths
mean that we can rejoice and be
glad
like Psalm 126 starts with it
says when the Lord restored the fortunes of
Zion.
We were like those who dream.
Our mouth was filled with laughter our
tongue with shouts of joy, and
then they said among the Nations the Lord
has done great things for them.
The Lord has done great things for
us. We are glad.
Are you glad Church?
Are you glad that our salvations are has come are
you glad that our wisdom has come are you glad that your future
is secure if you are we should
rejoice and be glad all day every
day. No matter what we face, right?
This I want to invite the worship leaders out. We're going to rejoice.
in that truth
that God has won. The battle. God is our Victory. God is
our salvation.
And so we should rejoice.
and be glad
we should not be sad about the gospel.
grieve your sin
but Rejoice that our Salvation has come.